INFORMATION PROTECTED BY
ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGE.
JOINING ME NOW IS MIKE DAVIS,
PRESIDENT OF THE ARTICLE THREE
PROJECT AND FORMER CLERK TO
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE NEIL
GORSUCH.
MIKE, DOES THIS MEAN THE REQUEST
FOR A SPECIAL MASTER DOESN'T
REALLY MATTER ANYMORE?
>> NOT AT ALL.
SO THE BIDEN JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
AND THE FBI HAS A PRETTY BAD
TRACK RECORD AS IT RELATES TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WE'VE SEEN THEY HAVE WEAPONIZED
AND POLITICIZED LAW ENFORCEMENT
REPEATEDLY TO GET TRUMP.
THIS WAS AN UNPRECEDENTED,
UNNECESSARY, UNLAWFUL HOME RAID
ON A FORMER PRESIDENT.
THE WHOLE LEGAL BASIS FOR THE
RAID HAS BEEN BLOWN APART.
THEY WENT AFTER TRUMP, THEY SAY
HE MAY HAVE VIOLATED THE
ESPIONAGE ACT THAT'S NOT EVEN
POSSIBLE AS THE COMMANDER IN
CHIEF HE CAN DECLASSIFY ANYTHING
HE WANTS.
THEY SAY HE MAY HAVE STOLE OR
MISUSED GOVERNMENT PROPERTY
UNDER THE PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS
ACT AND OTHER STATUTES.
THAT'S NOT POSSIBLE.
THERE'S A 2012 DECISION BY AN
OBAMA JUDGE THAT FORMER
PRESIDENTS CAN TAKE PERSONAL
RECORDS WITH THEM WHEN THEY
LEAVE OFFICE.
SO THERE GOES THE OBSTRUCTION
ALLEGATIONS.
IT'S LEGALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
OBSTRUCT NON-CRIMES LIKE THEY'RE
TRYING TO INVESTIGATE HERE.
THERE'S A TRACK RECORD OF LYING
IN THIS CASE.
THEY LEAKED OUT THAT ATTORNEY
GENERAL MERRICK GARLAND DID NOT
PERSONALLY APPROVE THIS RAID.
THAT'S A LIE.
THEY LEAKED OUT THAT TRUMP HAD
NUCLEAR DOCUMENTS AT MERRICK
GARLAND.
THAT'S A LIE.
THEY LEAKED OUT THAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN AND THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE
WAS NOT -- DID NOT HAVE A HEADS
UP ABOUT THIS RAID.
THAT'S A LIE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAD TO WAVE
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE IN ORDER TO PAVE THE
WAY FOR THIS RAID.
I THINK JUDGE CANNON UNDERSTANDS
THAT THEY ALSO, ATTORNEY GENERAL
MERRICK GARLAND SAID HE DLIB
RATEDED FOR WEEKS TO MAKE THIS
DECISION.
WELL, OKAY.
SO TRUMP HAD THESE DOCUMENTS FOR
18 MONTHS, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
HAD TO DELIBERATE FOR WEEKS, AND
THEY WAITED THREE DAYS AFTER
THEY HAD GOT A WARRANT FROM THIS
BIAS MAGISTRATE JUDGE BRUCE
REINHART, WHO JUST REDMUFD
TRUMP'S CIVIL LAWSUIT EIGHT
WEEKS AGO, SOMEHOW HIS BIAS WENT
AWAY.
IF TRUMP HAD SUCH DAMNING
RECORDS, WHY DID THEY WAIT SO
LONG?
WHY DID THEY WAIT TO GET THESE
DOCUMENTS.
>> Sean: GOOD POINT.
A CNN COUNTER-TERRORISM EXPERT
SAID THE DNI LEADING A DAMAGE
ASSESSMENT ON THE TRUMP
DOCUMENTS.
WATCH.
>> THIS IS A CURIOUS ONE BECAUSE
TYPICALLY BECAUSE IF YOU'RE
GOING TO DO A DAMAGE ASSESSMENT
YOU KNOW SOMETHING BAD HAS
ALREADY HAPPENED.
I DON'T MEAN SOMEBODY STORING
DOCUMENTS IMPROPERLY, I MEAN FOR
EXAMPLE A SPY GIVING AWAY
DOCUMENTS TO THE RUSSIANS.
>> Sean: MIKE WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT THE PHRASE DAMAGE
ASSESSMENT BEING USED HERE?
>> THEY ARE COVER THEIR TRACKS
BECAUSE THEY KNOW PRESIDENT
TRUMP DECLASSIFIED AND TOOK HIS
PERSONAL COPY OF THE CROSS FIRE
HURRICANE RECORDS RUSSIA
COLLUSION RECORDS AND THOSE ARE
DAMNING FOR BIDEN, OBAMA,
HILLARY, CLAPPER, SUSAN RICE,
THE FBI, THE INTEL COMMUNITY AND
THAT'S WHAT HAS TERRIFIED THEM
AND THAT'S WHAT HAS PRECIPITATED
THIS HOME RAID.
IT'S UNPRECEDENTED.
IT WAS UNNECESSARY AND UNLAWFUL
AND THAT'S WHY THEY DID THIS.
AND THIS IS A CLEANUP JOB.
>> Sean: MIKE, WHAT ARE THE NEXT
STEPS NOW FOR TEAM TRUMP?
WHERE DO THEY GO FROM HERE?
>> THEY'VE WON THIS PRELIMINARY
MOTION OR LOOKS LIKE JUDGE
CANNON'S GOING TO RULE IN THEIR
FAIR.
I THINK TRUMP NEEDS TO FILE AN
AMENDED RULE 41 G MOTION UNDER
THE FEDERAL RULES OF CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE TO GET BACK ALL OF
THIS PROPERTY, ALL THESE RECORDS
THAT WERE SEIZED BY THE BIDEN
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND HE CAN
TEA UP THESE LEGAL ISSUES RIGHT
NOW WITH JUDGE CANNON IN THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF FLORIDA,
GET THIS RESOLVED BY JUDGE
CANNON AND THE 11TH CIRCUIT
COURT OF APPEALS INSTEAD OF, YOU
KNOW, SOME TURN DERANGED
DEMOCRAT JUDGE IN THE DC
DISTRICT COURT AND THE DC COURT
OF APPEALS.
I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
LEGAL TEAM NEED TO GO